if the relationship blow off because of
this quote insulting free now we're told
James discussed hey Mariah six million a
year for every year they were married
with a max of a 30 million-dollar payout
me a source says various items were
thrown out at various points the prenup
never signed other details include James
could give Mariah her own credit card
her own private aircraft to use and a
wardrobe allowance but only outfits for
Mariah the singer had to shell out her
own cash for her kids clothes but
there's a new report today that claims
Mariah and James clashed over how Mimi
parented her five-year-old twins
Instagram video of the couples vacation
in Greece show rock and roll dancing and
jumping on top of a table in a
restaurant as Mariah looked on of course
it was their own Mama's music playing
but we spoke to Mariah last April she
told us James enjoyed her kids it seems
like he's getting on very well with rock
and roll he's very nice to them you know
he knows he's not that you know it's
it's they like him for as a friend it's
great